[Music]
welcome back
so this video lecture series has talked
about
how we can understand covid19 through
the lens of control theory
and in this video i want to summarize
some of what we have discussed in the
previous videos
and give some kind of summary of the
moral takeaways
of what we learn when we think about
this from the lens of control theory
now before i jump in there's a few
people i want to thank i want to thank
my wife bing brunton
for providing tons of feedback
and really valuable information and
general moral support when i was
developing this material
i'd also like to thank derek franz for
his help in producing these videos
okay so we're going to jump in and we're
going to summarize what we've learned so
far
and discuss some of the moral takeaways
so this is the diagram we've been
looking at throughout this series where
we are analyzing
the disease system the spread of the the
coronavirus through a population
and how through principled control
decisions and actions we can try to
suppress
this kind of runaway exponential spread
and maintain
a rate of infections that is manageable
with our current healthcare capacity
and i've stressed many many times the
importance of measuring
aspects of the system of really
measuring our system so that we can get
this feedback
signal so that we can get robust
performance
out of our controller we also need good
models of the system so that we can
predict what's going to happen
um you know in our system so
we've talked a lot about the texture and
the challenges of what make this
both interesting but also really hard
from a modeling and control standpoint
so and this is just a handful of some of
the challenges so there is uncertainty
in every aspect of this we have
uncertainty in our models
so i showed you all of those models and
none of them agreed
so we have uncertainty in our models our
measurements are noisy and imperfect so
there's uncertainty there
when we make a controlled decision when
we take action we don't know how
effective that's going to be that also
gives us uncertainty
and this makes sense this is we are the
controller every
human is part of this control strategy
it's our actions
that are changing the system and
whenever you deal with human dynamics
it's going to be messy so uncertainty is
just
part of the game we also have varying
parameters so this
system is constantly changing so as
different control
actions are being taken as the seasons
change as time goes on
uh you know all of the parameters of the
system are changing
and and that's part of what we're trying
to do is change these parameters through
control so that's also challenging
time delays are a major major problem
in control systems in general so if you
want really
fast aggressive feedback control
time delays can really hurt your
performance and and hamper that
robustness
and there's time delays in every aspect
of this there's time delays in your
measurements how long it takes to detect
if someone has this virus there's time
delays in the
transmission itself how long it takes to
transmit there's incubation periods
there's time delays in the controller
from when decisions happen
to when the actual actions take place
there's there's time delays
and so understanding how time delays
affect performance and what we
uh what we can expect out of our control
system is really important
and we also have fundamental limits on
on what kinds of control actions we can
take
so we only can do so much we can't you
know micromanage every
individual person's you know daily life
and nor do we want to we can't tell
people exactly what they can and can't
do and so there's limits on our control
also we don't want to you know shut down
essential services you can't shut down
the food supply chain you can't you know
we have to have firefighters and police
and medical workers and you know we have
to have that basic infrastructure so
there's limits on what we can do with
control
and and that's all you know wrapped up
into this control design
okay good so we've zoomed into the
disease system
and we've talked about various
strategies for building models
we have zoomed into the measurement
system and talked about the importance
of extensive
surveillance and measurements of our
system both for better control decisions
and to update our models as things
change
and we've also talked about various
control strategies once we have those
measurements once we have those models
how do we actually control our system
for example using
model predictive control okay so now i'm
going to talk about some of the kind of
morals
of what we've learned throughout this
process
so one of the key takeaway always that i
can't stress enough is that effective
feedback
control effective control using feedback
absolutely relies on sensors
sensor measurements are the lifeblood of
feedback control and you can't do it
without measurements
you can't suppress the system
if you had a blindfold on okay or at
least it's much much harder and you
can't expect your performance to be as
good
and also time delays are really
problematic
so reducing time delays anywhere
possible
is essential and we maybe can't control
the incubation time of the virus
so we should be focusing on getting
faster more
uh you know real-time sensor
measurements
and real-time control actions
so another thing we've talked about is
the importance of models
so i've talked about lots and lots of
different modeling strategies to
understand how this spreads and how we
can control it
and one of the points is that even
though all of these models
are different and most of them disagree
and there's no perfect model for this
disease system
even imperfect models can be very very
useful
for control theory and in fact
control theory this is maybe the biggest
point control theory
is a framework for balancing imperfect
models
and imperfect measurements to still make
good decisions and to still
have good performance that is what
control theory was designed to do
and that's what it's been doing for
decades in many many complex systems
like designing a robust and stable
internet or power grids or supply chains
control theory
is specifically designed to take
imperfect models and
imperfect measurements and combine them
to make good
robust decisions to get the performance
you need
and there's limitations on that and we
need to understand what those
limitations are
okay another point i want to make
is how essential it is to have
infrastructure in place
so there's lots of of groups
that are working really hard for
measuring the system for
for getting boots on the ground and
actually measuring the different
parameters of the system and how many
people are infected and
what strains there are and there's
groups that are modeling
uh the data and predicting what's going
to happen
and i think that we need to give a lot
of credit for the foresight
of having some of this infrastructure
already in place
but we also need to be investing in this
infrastructure in the future we need to
have
sensing and actuating infrastructure in
place
so in southeast asia they have a lot of
infrastructure in place because
of previous scares because of the sars
scares so they they after sars
developed a lot of this infrastructure
for surveillance networks and have this
in place
um when i think about this
infrastructure i can't help but think
about my field of aerospace engineering
where
like you would never get on an airplane
if you didn't believe
that that airplane already had the
sensors and the actuators
in place to control the system if you
thought that there was some instability
that that couldn't be detected with the
sensors on board and couldn't be
controlled
you shouldn't step foot on that airplane
and so we have known forever this is
just basic control design
that if you want to do a good job you
need sensors and you need actuators and
you need enough of them
to meet the specifications of your
control system okay so that's something
we need to be
to be thinking about i also want to
point out that success is not flashy
you're much more likely to hear about
this bridge than this bridge
and you know if we do our job i say we
because we are
all part of that controller we are all
individually all of our actions
are the control law and if we do our job
and the bridge doesn't collapse you know
that's a lot less flashy than if it does
collapse
and i think you know a lot of people are
already preparing for
if you know we get this under control
and things don't go
catastrophically wrong there are going
to be people that said that it wasn't
that big of a deal
all along this was you know this is just
a bad flu this is
you know it wasn't that big of a deal
and you know what we should be prepared
for that
sometimes when you do your job and
things don't go wrong you don't
necessarily get credit for that
but you know we still want to divide
develop you know stable bridges that
don't collapse
okay um there's kind of a meta
point here that i've been thinking about
a lot and i haven't really addressed
that much in any of the
specific videos so i want to talk about
here which is
uh what cost function are we optimizing
so any of you who know me and who've
you know watched my my bootcamp on
control theory
know that i view control theory
essentially as applied optimization
your control design is basically you're
trying to optimize
some cost function given the constraints
of your system given what you can
measure
and what the dynamics of your system are
you're trying to optimize your
controller
for some overarching cost function and
this
is kind of problematic when we have
something so societally important
like the the spread of covid19 obviously
lives are are critical we don't want
people to die we want to save lives
there's also livelihoods we we want
people to get back to work we want kids
to go back to school
this is a huge you know there's a huge
economic and societal impact as well for
the control actions that we're taking
and how do you balance those
those cost functions that's incredibly
challenging
but i think we do have to be aware that
at some level
this is we are trying to optimize
something and this is
uh in my mind this is one of the reasons
you need leadership this is one of the
most clear
motivations for leadership is when you
have these really hard optimization
problems and hard cost functions
that any one of us you know shouldn't
necessarily be defining
that's when you need leadership is to
kind of make those decisions about what
matters
when and how um i think that's really
important to think about so as we
as we phase in the workforce and we
start getting kids back to school
you know how are we going to optimize
this system
to you know save lives but also you know
save
livelihoods as well that's that's really
important
okay so this has been a lecture series
on
understanding covid19 from the control
theory perspective
there's going to be lots of hard
decisions ahead
and i hope that this has been
educational and i hope
that we recognize that those hard
decisions should be made at least with
knowledge
of control theory and kind of everything
we know about how to interact with
complex systems
like the spread of a disease i'm steve
brenton
thank you very much for watching